quest'anno festeggia i 30 anni da quando
iniziato a utilizzare videogiochi
ora un mi chiederò di farmi gli auguri
le celebrazioni perché immagino che in
sala se ho tante persone come i miei
genitori che hanno sempre reputato
questa che stata prima una mia passione
poi dettato il mio lavoro
qualcosa nella migliore delle ipotesi
una perdita di tempo se non addirittura
cose peggiori non hanno mai compreso
però io in questi anni ho guidato per
milioni di km ho visitato tantissimi i
territori che non ho mai potuto
visionare dal vivo ho salvato
principesse sono sono morto e risorto
tantissime volte ho potuto fare tante
azioni che solitamente ho viaggiato
nello spazio che noi esseri umani sono
precluse
ma soprattutto ha incontrato e
conosciuto tante persone reali
accomunate da questa mia stessa passione
le ho conosciute sui forum di
videogiochi le ho conosciute all'interno
dei mondi virtuali conosciute agli
eventi riguardo i videogiochi oggi
volevo parlarvi di un ragazzo che un mio
amico ha 17 anni
questa è una foto puramente fittizia
rappresentativa questo mio amico a
scuola va malissimo è stato bocciato già
due volte quando sua mamma va ai
colloqui le insegnanti dico veramente
peste e corna perché li comandano non va
bene disturba fa fatica a relazionarsi
secondo noi gli mancano proprio dei set
cognitivi quindi niente dei giudizi
assurdi quello stesso ragazzino incontro
ogni sera all'interno di un videogioco
sapete nei videogiochi si può giocare
anche online e ci si incontra
utilizzando inter ci si può operare
competere così di averlo incontri uno di
questi videogiochi
l'ho conosciuto così prima in maniera
virtuale per me è una delle persone più
intelligenti che abbia mai conosciuto
lui presente gestisce da solo un clan di
oltre 100 persone reali a cui ogni
giorno assegnare i compiti fa
progettazione a medio breve e lungo
periodo
ha grandissime capacità di problem
solving estremamente creativo lui
gestisce persone anche che hanno 30 40
50 anni manager di aziende dell un
ragazzo di 17 anni
quello che mi ha sempre fatto riflettere
come è possibile
da una parte questo ragazzo vanno
malissimo a scuola gli si dicono che è
una persona lì è nata che non avrà un
futuro dall'altra ma nei videogiochi ed
è veramente più grande stratega
possibile di questo mondo allora la
domanda è non è che forse il sistema
quale concepito il mondo attuale che non
è giusto non permette soprattutto le
generazioni di esprimersi e di e di
mettere alla prova le loro le loro
capacità questo il caso di questo mio
amico umberto non è un caso isolato
ci sono delle statistiche ci dicono che
il 70 per cento delle persone che
popolano il mondo e scarsamente o per
nulla coinvolto con quello che fa
quotidianamente cioè va a scuola si reca
sul luogo di lavoro
interagisce con altre persone in maniera
disallineata in maniera quasi annoiata
cosa significa significa questo perdere
tantissimo in termini di produttività di
capacità di proattività di suggerimenti
ci sono persone ma dico anche i miei
colleghi i miei amici si recano in
ufficio dove vengono pagati alcuni anche
bene sono totalmente disallineati con la
missione con la visione dell'azienda poi
fanno altre cose dove addirittura
spendono i loro soldi ma in queste cose
sono coinvolte e li diventano dei
supereroi sono e sono anche proattivi
rilasciano idee sono propositivi
c'è un problema e io credo che una
parola che per me centrale dovrebbe
diventare centrale nelle politiche
coinvolgimento c'è scritto anche un
libro uscito due settimane fa su questo
tema l'arte del coinvolgimento cioè
quanto è importante riappropriarsi di
questo termine di questa dimensione cioè
trasformare una trasformazione di ogni
esperienza quotidiana dal dover a voler
fare noi finora siamo stati abituati
soprattutto le generazioni precedenti a
fare le cose per obblighi nour ali per
obblighi sociali perché si è sempre
fatto in quel modo perché i nostri
genitori hanno fatto così si sposavano a
vent'anni poi facevano due figli
quando entravano in ufficio alle 9 poi
secondo l'ufficio alle 18
a un certo punto della vita vi si
considerava vecchie ci si ritirava e
lidia invece che dobbiamo provare a
ricambiare questo mondo ed è l'unico
modo per riappropriarsi di queste
generazioni che stiamo perdendo quindi
possiamo andare anche avanti con la
slide io credo che più che tante
tecnologie più che dei soldi il
coinvolgimento è uno dei pochi motori a
costo zero che possono imprimere un
cambiamento delle nostre esistenze
il coinvolgimento poi contagioso se ci
fate caso quando le persone coinvolte in
qualsiasi cosa anche una semplice
passione
vedete gli occhi si illuminano inizia a
dedicarsi anche 50 ore senza
accorgersene lavora anche di notte peso
al modellismo facciamo un esempio
poi partecipa alle fiere valli cerca
altre persone vuole vuole condividere
con altri questa propria passione si
nutre si nutre di quello che fanno anche
gli altri ricerca queste dinamiche anche
sociali diventa una persona
sostanzialmente migliore possiamo dire
quello che io dico è che non serve non
sempre serve per forza una tecnologia
per forza tanti soldi per cambiare
questo mondo
io qui porto due esempi 1 banalissimo
questo è un coinvolgimento di tipo base
sono tanti tipi coinvolgimento
immaginate un piatto di verdura non lo
so noi siamo i nostri bambini attingete
alla vostra esperienza personale perché
sia figli un piatto river 200 g di
broccoli difficilmente vengono mangiati
da un bambino piccolo se quella stessa
quantità di verdura viene riproposta
all'interno di una mail di una metafora
un topolino all'interno di colori
all'interno di forme quella quantità
viene forse più facilmente mangiata da
un bambino
un altro esempio banale questo ho
insegnato ha fatto il giro del mondo
questa storia molto recente questo è
barry white junior è un insegnante di
inglese in una crisi americana di primo
grado cosa fa così è inventato c'è
problema soprattutto nelle scuole di
come relazionarsi con i ragazzi sempre
meno sempre più di s'ingaggia theora lui
è inventato un saluto personalizzato che
ogni mattina appena entra in classe fa
con ciascuno degli studenti davanti alla
porta un saluto di quelli morto
provenienti dalla cultura afro per cui
c'è un misto di ballo
questi rituali o con ognuno un saluto
diverso in base alla personalità di
questo ragazzo qui c'è questo i ragazzi
poi stati questo avviene già da diversi
anni ragazzi in classe ora rendono
tantissimo di più hanno un rapporto
diverso
questo cosa vuol dire che semplicemente
passando dall idea di una
standardizzazione sulla quale si perde
ancora oggi larga parte del nostro mondo
appunto a tarvisio industriale passando
all'idea della personalizzazione
dell'esperienza è possibile cambiare il
comportamento delle persone
abbiamo avanti e ora io non sono un
sociologo psicologo faccio videogiochi
ho lavorato per altro le carceri 20 per
chi conosce queste aziende fifa sims e
tecnici ma la cosa che più imparato in
questi anni al litro dell'industria è
stata l'osservazione delle nuove
generazioni
noi non siamo venti di ricerca però
analizziamo i dati di milioni di persone
che acquistano i nostri giochi sappiamo
in tempo reale che spade stanno
comprando quanto tempo stanno nel gioco
quante volte sono rientrate abbiamo un
infinità di dati di queste persone e poi
li analizziamo come te mi servono per
creare dei giochi migliori o per fargli
spendere di più desta brutalmente però
al di là di questo inciso
quello che è interessante osservare che
queste generazioni soprattutto le due
nuove io dico i nati dopo i 980 per dare
una cesoia giusto simbolica la
generazione y e poi quella z dei nati
dopo il 2000 presenta dei forti
distacchi rispetto alle generazioni
precedenti cioè il distacco che c'è tra
un ragazzo di 20 anni e suo nonno è 100
volte maggiori rispetto al distacco che
c'era tra il mio bisnonno e suo nonno
perché il mondo è cambiato il mondo sia
iter accelerato e ci sono dei tratti di
queste generazioni che sono interessanti
da osservare soprattutto importanti da
conoscere per progettare coinvolgimento
il cambiamento per dare un dato
interessante questo è uno di quelli
magari sono più strano ora non so se sia
vero proprio nella proporzione ma poi ve
lo posso testimoniare la curva media di
attenzione di circa 8 secondi è
notevolmente notevolmente abbassata agli
ultimi 100 anni questo non vuol dire che
una persona non sia in grado di
mantenere attenzione per per ore quando
è coinvolto ma di base abbiamo una curva
di attenzione inferiore a quella di un
pesciolino rosso perché siamo guardati
da stimoli
ognuno di noi oggi può accedere a
milioni di brani musicali in tempo reale
può accedere a milioni film sun
click si può andare su youtube può
parlare dunque sono dall'altra parte del
mondo può crearsi oggetti quasi in casa
le stampanti 3d
eppure è una generazione che ha un dato
che fa riflettere
negli ultimi 50 anni il tasso dei
suicidi aumentato del 60 per cento
ora questo è un dato che stona con tutto
quello che è cambiato abbiamo tantissime
azioni potenziali da fare c'è il mio
nonno ha vissuto con 10 stimoli in tutta
la sua vita aveva proprio difficoltà ad
accedere in un paesino c'era interesse
quasi non c'era il telefono faceva
sempre le stesse cose in modo rituale
questi ragazzi invece possono accedere a
un infinità di azioni in grado di
riempire ogni secondo delle 24 ore
addirittura molto di più perché si parla
di un'azione multitasking se andiamo a
sommare le azioni che fanno in una
giornata alcune persone arriviamo a 26
27 28 reti in contemporanea possono fare
addirittura più cose e alcuni
parzialmente si concentrano facendo più
cose in contemporanea però il numero sui
sicilia aumentato tantissimo prodotto
dalle generazioni e parzialmente però
queste stesse generazioni che spesso
quando si parla con insegnati dicono
essere un po non dico stupidi però a
volte mi è capitato queste queste
situazioni meno di 50 anni hanno visto
il cosiddetto tale tipo brescia di 15
punti
qui c'è qualcosa che non torna qualcosa
che non torna insomma il corto circuito
che è nato tra le aspettative gli
interessi le necessità di queste nuove
generazioni e come il mondo è costruito
ancora largamente intorno ai principi
del settecento ottocento e poi del
novecento era un mondo che più o meno a
mio nonno potrò andare ancora bene era
cresciuto con la guerra era cresciuto
con la leva militare per cui c'era un
senso di di gerarchia definito un senso
di verticalità un senso di burocrazia ma
quando io anche i miei amici con
fruttare un ente pubblico che risponde
dopo sei mesi deve stare cinque ore in
coda dal dottore sono tutte cose che
sono abbastanza allenanti rispetto a
quello che si fa nel resto della
giornata in cui se tu mandi un messaggio
un amico era entro due minuti non ti
risponde su whatsapp inizia sclerare
tiro ma perché non mi sta rispondendo
mio nonno invece manda una lettera a mia
nonna e deve aspettare un mese prima che
mia nonna risponde essere capitano in
due città diverse
il proprio cambiato
andiamo avanti e va avanti e ora vi
mostro tre cose presenti la mondeo già
quindi come poi videogiochi possono
entrare nella vita reale o i videogiochi
sono una cosa molto grande e ormai 20
milioni di persone in italia
riutilizzano in italia si spende un
miliardo di euro in videogiochi nel
mondo 100 miliardi di euro quasi un
miliardo di persone già utilizzano i
videogiochi nel mondo quindi è molto
pervasivo è il media principale col
quale stanno crescendo una generazione
purtroppo per fortuna sono dal punto di
vista più dei libri più del cinema
chiude la musica per consumi intesa sia
come spesa sia come tempo davanti
presenti ora noi stiamo lavorando un
videogioco per il museo archeologico
nazionale di napoli e il primo caso in
cui il museo diventa un publisher
videogioco il videogioco non richiama
nel titolo nella fruizione il museo
l'idea quale era era intercettare nuovi
pubblici a 3 su un videogioco il
videogioco in distribuito a livello
mondiale in italiano ed inglese sugli
store di distribuzione non entro nel
tecnico cui vi faccio vedere un breve
video e poi vi racconto una prosa
[Musica]
ci troviamo ricostruito napoli figata
tutto a mano chilometri di strade per
immergere il giocatore il gioco e
seguenti 4 aprile due cose interessanti
il gioco è stato annunciato il 24
gennaio e ha ottenuto già 175
pubblicazioni in tutto il mondo da el
pais e riviste americane in italia tutti
e il tb rai sky qualsiasi altro quindi
già proprio a livello di investimento il
museo ha recuperato quanto ha speso cioè
se avesse dovuto acquistare quegli spazi
all'interno di questi media
internazionali avrebbe speso molto di
più
la seconda cosa interessante all'interno
del gioco che fruibile anche da persone
che non verranno mai al museo ma c'è una
funzionalità sono interessante aventi
mentato è se tu poi ti rete a napoli il
sistema fa un check in e riconosce in
automatico che tu sia al napoli che sia
il museo aties blocca delle funzionalità
nuove all'interno del gioco
questo è un sistema per collegare poi il
fisico e digitale per non lasciare solo
l'esperienza digitale avanti i
videogiochi come possono servire un so
se conoscete assassin's creed è un gioco
della ubisoft è stato ambiente è
ambientato in varie città italiane tra
cui anche monteriggioni questo gioco ha
venduto riceva i capitoli decine di
milioni di copie e decine di milioni
persone nel mondo sono venuto a
conoscenza e monteriggioni attraverso i
video gioco perché nel 2009 il flusso
turistico mentre il giorno aumentato
circa mille per cento
monteriggioni finito al guggenheim
museum con una riproduzione perché il
direttore ha scoperto che esiste
monteriggioni attraverso il videogioco
quindi o giochi possono aiutare anche
creare dei cortocircuiti reali
questo è un caso ma in italia esistono
centinaia di video giochi e molto spesso
i comuni non sanno che i giochi che
hanno venduto decine di unicoop e del
mondo sono iniettate nella loro città
quindi questo è un lavoro di
sensibilizzazione che andrà fatto avanti
questo è un esempio un altro progetto da
due anni lavoro cassazione italiani
editori sono mondadori feltrinelli
nonché su di provare a disegnare un modo
per coinvolgere le persone alla lettura
c'è qualcuno di voi conosce iniziativa
io leggo perché ricettiva annuale a
parte l'anno scorso anno ci ha
accompagnato da un sito web in questo
sito web sono degli elementi tratti dai
videogiochi e così dettagli fiction cosa
di consentì fare abbiamo creato delle
missioni con dei badge dei punti delle
classifiche
missioni di vario tipo va in strada e
fare una foto mentre scatto una foto
mentre legge un libro va dal tuo
librario fi quest altra azione pole e
carichi sulla piattaforma le condivide
sugli altri
se clicchi risultati sono stati
incredibili constatando che qui il
target medio sono donne sui 40 anni il
lettore tipo se va avanti con la slide
abbiamo avuto sanzioni da 100 mila
missioni superate in tre mesi abbiamo
avuto 54mila contenuti caricati e
bisognava raggiungere un certo numero di
punti per diventare messaggeri della
lettura abbiamo avuto 25 mila persone
che hanno superato queste missioni una
volta diventi messaggio della lettura
che arrivano a casa questi libri che
devi regalare ad altre persone leader a
questa di creare revocazione questo e
per dire come sia possibile
implementarlo anche in contesti che
apparentemente molto lontane target
molto lontani tra tra slide
questo però è un progetto il quale non
c'entro io e viene dall'inghilterra su
messa ordinario si chiama gallo lampo e
vincitore di un premio inglese che si
chiama playball city è un premio che si
è una call in cui si vincono poi 20mila
sterline aperta tutto il mondo in cui si
invitano gli inventori a creare delle
soluzioni per rendere maggiormente
coinvolgente e divertente il nostro
tessuto urbano questo progetto
semplicissimo si basa su una piattaforma
sms ti consente di interagire e parlare
con l'arredo urbano
vai davanti alla cassetta delle lettere
un albero una panchina
scrivi e lo più il numero seriale
scritto vicino alla panchina più quello
che vuoi e ti risponde in maniera
intelligente a un algoritmo che auto
apprende per cui capta le storie delle
persone e le restituisce in qualche modo
quindi dice guarda che qui appena
passato un ragazzo che si è baciato
sotto questo lampione opportuno può
insultare gli puoi dire qualsiasi cosa e
lampione ti risponde questo ora è
diventata pratica a bristol a tokyo ad
austin quindi in varie città la cosa
interessante da un punto distante noi
che facciamo videogiochi molto simile al
principe degli avatar
ci si lega con un oggetto il tasso di
vandalismo in questa città è diminuito
perché gli oggetti pulizia percepire
come qualcosa di vivo e non più come un
arredo che non appartiene a nessuno ma
un ente che nel bene o nel male col
quale si può dialogare lo può insultare
ci può emozionare insieme questo è molto
semplice non aveva più interessanti
d'altra slide
questa non so quanti voi la conoscono
foldit è una piattaforma americana è
molto simile a concetti e luzzati prima
dal professor di partecipazione di
persone normalissime scollegate dalla
medicina questo consente attraverso un
gioco stile puzzle di sintetizzare le
proteine sono state fatte delle scoperte
da centinaia e migliaia di persone che
stanno giocando che nel laboratorio
state scoperte sud in ambito dell'aids
in dieci giorni di gioco centinaia di
persone che giocano insieme perché
questi dati poi confluiscono in maniera
diversa scientifica nei laboratori
quindi vi ho fatto vedere alcuni metodi
ora l'ultima slide per chiudere quello
che io sogno un mondo in cui quello che
più imparato il game over sia un nuovo
modo di dire apprendimento perché quando
sbagliamo nei videogiochi stiamo
crescendo grazie
[Applauso]